[Music]
Sam you're using your mouth yes
were you using your tongue do you fit
all fixation maybe like oral I enjoy it
very much your finger banging your mouth
while you're jerking off [ __ ] yeah no I
do not do the like then have you ever
fish another one second wait let's bring
it back let's make it back
so back to the tongues what would you do
if you found a whole bunch of jars
tongue of tongue human-like language
yeah at the taco truck
oh damn if they're cardi B tongues I'm
for it what I'm assuming I'm not
assuming were links the [ __ ] floor
dude Shakira maybe you got a Kermit
Shakira voice going on oh hey maybe we
could she is pretty her MIDI or was this
happen he died this was in Florida in
Gainesville Florida
ah you [ __ ] meet it that's how you
know you're [ __ ] Fitness like I'm in
Gainesville all day
[Applause]
Gainesville bro [ __ ] room even caught
it [ __ ] sad about it I wish I live in
Gainesville if you don't work out for a
long time and then you flex don't you
get a cramp you fart I pull a muscle but
it hurts my back I'm all [ __ ] wait he he
is an oral pathologist and professor at
the University of Florida and he had
moved out of his home back in 1992 after
a divorce but his ex-wife still owns
that home oh my god so when she was
trying to get some work done on the home
she won the [ __ ] jar of tongs huh
that's why any contractor went into the
crawlspace below the house and found all
these jars all these jars lots of pull
jars have half a dozen plastic gallon
size jars containing human tongue Oh
why do sirico has always neat trophies
why yeah wait because I just thought
this guy was into the mouth [ __ ]
and if he was waiting at the [ __ ]
like morgue or like oh I just collecting
tongue hey you guys gonna beat that tub
before they'll you know y'all gonna use
that time yeah tongue fetishes yeah I
think it was sexual I thought he was
just a collector cuz he's so passionate
about mouth [ __ ] okay so what the [ __ ]
all right okay tongues Joe is really
closest because he was saving those
tongues for research but he never got
around to them and the reason why
they're under the house in the crawl
space is because that was a cool place
[ __ ] that's all [ __ ] weird
putting their pantry then wait what
your pants are weirder one two five ribs
I got fruit roll-ups I gotta keep kids
sitting up some tongs away oh yeah won't
you get like a medical fridge or some
why what's wrong with him pointing it at
win the [ __ ] cross baby Oh what's
wrong they're putting in the crawl space
we'll say it out loud Gio I literally
did high I put all of my human tongues
in the crawl space yeah well why do you
even have human tongues if you're gonna
happen you should go to jail for that
Center where'd he get them from you got
him from the school cuz he is a pristine
something wrong we have wall space Steve
I got her back all day long yeah because
they get body parts yeah that's why he
was holding on to them see what's wrong
with that
yeah what's wrong the crawlspace so
weird yes photos I have a question so
what I've done I've stigmatized crawl
spaces preserve it looks like so now the
high maybe not a jarful I'm missing you
all the time okay well it doesn't need
to be revised you see that looks like a
meth lab I don't like it why do they
open it with it's just straight-up yeah
last jar were looking seashells I
thought it wasn't like those 19:20 like
those jars these jars are very tasteful
to cancel too because I was picturing it
like when you go to the museum and have
a snake in the jar liquid there's a
light illuminating red light green light
oh yeah like when I was looking for
brains and [ __ ] yeah what happened
it was anticlimactic I'm sorry yeah just
like when I use my tongue what a [ __ ]
lot of God a bit so what I heard you
right
we get back to my imagination Phase III
detective eyes this [ __ ] too good right
yeah I think this guy was using these
tugs to [ __ ] lick his dick you know
but they were driving yeah why wouldn't
he okay
here mouth I hear mouth who's the tongue
to put on his tongue to taste the tongue
have you ever tried tasting your tongue
you got that huh mm-hmm
it feels weird it tastes really good oh
do you guys ever tickle the roof of your
mouth just ever so like caress ever saw
I think that makes me want to sneeze
okay everybody can know cuz that is
genetic though its genetic but you know
what sucks about it
you can't look big [ __ ] better with
that yeah you can't go guys you're not
supposed to wrap around the clip oh yeah
you are baby it's like this listen can
you do this like this look it's actually
watch hmm good control hmm they do it
how do you think your tongue out so far
I did it look TIFF you should eat [ __ ]
straighter can anybody do that the
triple W and what would that do for
someone do it I used to before I don't
know if I can so you haven't practiced
ee oh I haven't seen it since high
school
yeah why am i doing that so close to the
[ __ ] camera [ __ ] because you want
to show women that you can do it no no
[ __ ] opening my mouth close to the
camera you're empowering other women
yeah yours d stigmatizing it oh you flip
that [ __ ] upside down yeah yeah yeah you
do tricks
yeah oh
[Laughter]
I can do it you can even do it damn it I
used to be able to leave me too baby
oh yeah maybe yeah put some water on
there cuz it's just thinking a little
bit oh my god I pushed her luck as a
sport yeah we know well I have a system
this is one with spectators what a
system it's just the same every time
yeah I I get I get a hug invite I get a
[ __ ] towel out and I'm gonna [ __ ]
lay that [ __ ] out like a butler I say
please and I get I get that's the that's
my setup yeah I'm not gonna tell you my
technique is a secret after do you pull
it and then she saw it I lay in the
checkout and then I take it off
immediately [ __ ] quite a fixer only if
there's no hot sauce Geo I smash you
guys see the sexual Taoists guy that I
put on my son so there's this extra
material no no I sent it to you oh wait
I don't wanna guy who smells the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the most conscious girls at the part
yeah and he's doing an ancient asian
massage and then like he visits her butt
cheek she goes
oh my god like for longer yeah God and
in the girl light looks like pocket it's
like in public like it's an ancient
massage he starts off like a normal
massage hmm and he literally sticks his
face in her ass I went fart I recently
got my ass massaged did he stick his
nose yeah in your [ __ ] yoga pants but
the female TFG that's that's different
okay so the guy that Bart saw is that I
put on he thought he was on the London
real and he's like he's a he's like a
sexual energy guy and he's literally
talking about all the ways to last
longer too [ __ ] generate this [ __ ]
Chi and all that and he's explaining how
to [ __ ] eat [ __ ] mmm
and he goes you have to practice right
oh the Asian guy yeah oh you did send me
this yeah and he has a he has a method
of stretching out your dick and becoming
harder and while you're simultaneously
sticking your tongue out and exercising
imagine that someone that looks like
your dad ah it looks like you're dead
and so and he's doing a do so various
yeah anyways you have to stretch out
your tongue pull your peanut you put
actually pause oh no no no he's fully
clothed yeah but it's free what's his
[ __ ] home it's like a 13 year old
boys like and then you flex the nipple
like I keep treated that's all the girls
he's ever had sex with yeah I want to
know they're smoking cigarettes like
Manny 50 bugs
they look like hookers a lot of issues
now he's sweaty
he just hit like 70 and he still [ __ ]
his wife like every night Wow
yes several kids right no I think yes I
like his whole thing is like channeling
sexual energy like it's like a it's like
a man he doesn't [ __ ] music well
I've seen that you're feeling hard right
harder and you're like no there is
tantric sex if I don't if that's tension
so yeah it's not touching well the thing
that energy thing though isn't that like
it's a combo it's like it's like sexual
Taoism or something this guy talks about
eating [ __ ] too much to beat answering
another thing that I took away from it
that I thought was pretty [ __ ] cool
is he's teaching guys how to have
multiple orgasms like women and the
whole club and it is it's almost like
edging and he's like you're not supposed
to ejaculate right I've heard that
because you know that she right uh in
the in the whole Taoists cheap thing
right if you come lose all your powers
exactly so it gets going based off of
that so then he depends what if you're
so [ __ ] horny haven't come in like
nine days he's like if you come like
once or twice a month or whatever it's
fine but the goal is to to save that and
didn't like recycle it is he patient
that come on the lunar calendar no but
it's like but it's so like you know how
like you like women can come multiple
time right but he's like you cannot
ejaculation you think when you
ejaculation you waste it so he's like so
he's like you edge right about the point
we're about to come and he goes you were
last oh I can never me neither like
that's crazy he goes and you what am I
supposed to do go outside jog around the
block that's crazy talk not jogging
around the bar [ __ ] that yeah I'm not
jogging on the Block period can leave me
I'm coming I'm coming and then I'm using
more I supposed to eat to get hard again
yeah the way Amanda does it [ __ ] bust
inside that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] slurp out to come and spit
it in her mouth place yeah
spit it back to me you [ __ ] it yeah are
you [ __ ] coward yeah and is she
sitting back and you make out with the
car make out with a cry that's what real
men do jean-claude Van Damme [ __ ] you
[Music]